[Music]
our next guest is a comedian who's
making her late night debut with us here
tonight and can be seen regularly
headlining the comedy and magic club in
hermosa beach california please welcome
the very funny cristela alonso
[Music]
you guys i'm so excited to be here uh i
almost didn't make it though i was at
home watching my favorite show 16 i'm
pregnant i love this show because i love
when bad things happen to bad people oh
my god
if you think your life sucks watch this
show you'll feel so much better about
yourself because these girls are so
[ __ ] you just want to hit them you
know whatever i'm pregnant
whatever big deal i'm still going to
party this
then the moment they go into labor
they're like oh my god i'm like
[Laughter]
it hurts right
oh i hope you have twins
can't believe there's so much crap on tv
guys like i can't believe the jersey
shore is as big as it is
like my niece tans all the time because
of the show
let me say that again my mexican niece
tans all the time because of this show
like when you think about it tanning is
such a double standard because white
people can go and be dark for a week i
can't go anywhere enlightened
i like hearing white girls talk to their
friends hey girl you want to go tan
let's go be ethnic for a week
[Laughter]
don't worry we're still white
it's a double standard white people you
have tanning boots there's no bleaching
booth for me like hey i need to be two
shades wider this week i've got a job
interview
[Music]
you guys ever lied so much on a resume
you're actually shocked that they give
you the job
like you lie so much you want to have a
talk with the company to make sure
they're not messing with you you know
like apes come here
are you sure about this
look at me look at my resume
do i look like an astronaut
like when i lie i go all the way i'm not
gonna do that whole hey i type 80 words
a minute i'm like screw it i went to the
moon
and i do that because my sister
is my fake boss
for every fake job i've ever had so when
you're calling to check references
you're never calling a real company
you're calling my sister's house and you
always know it's crap because she's this
like 40 year old mexican mother of three
so every time she answers the phone
she's like hello
yes as nasa
oh yes with the chattels and the rockets
yes yes yes yes said he'll get off the
bed what
yeah she's the best astronaut that we've
got yes yes she goes to the moon like
five times a week it's crazy
get off the stupid bed right now
oh no i'm not busy no no i'm in the
middle of a countdown
[Applause]
[Music]
here's the thing though guys as i'm
getting older i've realized that as a
latina there's certain activities i just
can't do because i'm mexican and that
struggle you know like a couple years
ago i dated this white guy on our fourth
date he's like hey this weekend
let's drive upstate we'll pick some
apples it'll be romantic
what
say this weekend we'll drive upstate
we'll pick some apples it'll be nice
no
two white people picking apples that's a
romantic date me i'm a migrant farm
worker do you understand that
like i would be afraid that they would
let him go but i'd have to stay to meet
my quota for the day
i'll see you at dinner
[Applause]
i'm a tomboy i grew up a tomboy with
brothers you know i'm not a very
feminine girl which is weird i can't
pull it off that's why i'm so jealous of
girls that can do it you know you always
see those girls dressed up sexy on the
weekends with their low-cut blouses it's
like they're saying oh yeah
come and get it
the worst is around halloween because
that's when they dress up in those like
[ __ ] costumes you know
oh
i'm a sexy french maid
[Music]
i can't do that
i just look like a maid
that's the last thing i need is for me
to try to turn my boyfriend on and he's
like look who's doing some cleaning all
right here's my laundry thank guys my
name is thank you guys thank you
that's great
great job
really hilarious
[Applause]